it's a crazy world but that's it that's
how you bring on the road yeah
Marc opens for me on the road just him
yeah just sometimes I'll have a local
guy yeah I like psycho guy yeah yeah
usually can get in I see though Kevin
that's a thing we could we could be like
I feel like when it's dicey it's fun
mm-hmm
feel it's fun when Stacy yeah I try I
bring an opener and a feature you bring
both yes but for the long really I would
just roll the dice I found it was kind
of fun you fly them out oh yeah and
everything people see that the thing is
I already have out so I'm flying two
guys out I know we were always thinking
we just got to get out five minutes know
them focus on that video bro we had out
we had I'll do uh yeah I'll do one joke
we're in Tampa and Brockamp improv we
were gonna do it for the we have video
of it in the drop it in series right
into the drop so we're at a taffeta prop
and we're like he'll I'll just do a joke
I'll give you one of my old jokes
hilarious right and you just go up there
do the joke will be a quick little
misdirection to open it up to open the
show no I bought him up we were in my
set I brought during my sets off but
everybody knows him like Alice you know
synonymous with me so yeah you know I'm
right so it was like he goes up we
stopped the show he comes up right he
goes this is a joke and it's one of the
first jokes I ever wrote this is like 12
13 years ago right and the joke was I
like it when a girl talk is dirty a bit
I just hate it when they repeat the same
thing over and over again right like no
so that's the joke and I say I go I say
how I say I go listen I'm gonna set it
up so they know it's a joke right
because it's a harsh joke but I'm gonna
fill it up know what's wrong cause
tonight's overflow but here's the thing
okay so wait hold up before you go on
how long ago is this this is six months
ago three months ago I see oh come on my
graphic with it you might onstage so
about raping [ __ ] it was like oh oh
wow it just got dark man you got real
dark so now goes onstage he comes over
me right and I go out you gotta let
before I go out let me preface it
because if it's such a great
misdirection that they're gonna laugh no
matter what they're just gonna laugh the
misdirection that kind of care about the
rape right yeah but I don't explain that
to him I just go just let me preface it
yeah so he comes up and then he goes and
I go I go now I just wanna and he goes
he goes it looks at me goes not got this
before I start you know you know I hate
I hate when girls talk dirty I just hate
when they say the same thing over and
over again now they're taking him
serious in this moment right because
he's saying before I really it's not a
joke
right and then he goes you know like
stop stop the [ __ ] crowd is horrified
no wait it's my favorite part right else
is there for a second
confidence my lady goes that's my time
y'all I wish you like cami
yeah it's you nervous swag man sometimes
those openers are funny like it just in
Tampa is when open for you Oh name
she bought myself bring anyone I just
went to Carla how quickly is that I
didn't want to say her name you don't
remember her name
why yeah I remember this one because
because I did Palm Beach Orlando and
Tampa and I rented a car I'd had no
future nothing I just have them into
this drive around all ya [ __ ] cities
so hey so my youth Tampa and it was
theirs though is the last stop my tour
I'm tired I'm in the back I'm waiting
I'm waiting and the manager comes up it
goes hey man
so uh we got this female open up free
man and I go ah dude it's kind of tough
my crowd so bro we sometimes the females
have to be so good I'd like to just
check out yes dude trust me she'll burn
up for Delia she's fantastic
so it takes two Leah you know dude do
you remember blah blah blah how oh is
she in all capitals you put horrible
so I'm like ah dude
so the
so then that she's the featured emcee
comes in he's this little little Jewish
guy goes what's up man he's like all
sweaty I'm like what's up dude he goes
nothing your features my axe man she
came here with a [ __ ] a boyfriend he
goes dude dude I'm a fan if he tries
doing some [ __ ] will you help me out
dude I'm like what is happening yeah and
I go I literally I'm like I don't dude
I'll just see you at the show so he goes
back there this girl walks in her man is
oh I don't know 6-8 job dude Jack I'm
like what is happening here and she's
all oh my [ __ ] boyfriend your MC my
ex he's so annoying I'm like alright see
you guys out there
MC goes out eats all the dicks doesn't
do well brings out the feature but he's
like real cat he's like alright
everybody give her a [ __ ] Janeane
she's been she's alright Brit give it up
for so the audience is like half ass she
goes out crickets crickets and she goes
oh you know what no you know what [ __ ]
you guys she does this is Mike result
out Congress I've been doing comedy for
12 years Brendan's been doing for five
[ __ ] weeks [ __ ] you guys I'm gonna
get my time beer bottle cool I had a
girl girl didn't hit her just onstage
they start booing her but this [ __ ]
does hurt she gets her Taemin oh she
does her time and then go and zip goes
[ __ ] y'all puts the mic and I'm saying
the back head what the [ __ ] she owes
sorry bro
just walks off dude and then I walked
out I just go up the crowds chair and I
just go how about that [ __ ] crazy I
can't believe they threw a beer bottle
oh yeah
[ __ ] done [ __ ] I had a woman was it a
girl who threw it I don't know it had to
be I'm backstage I'm like it's [ __ ]
yeah it's the purge up you got to go you
have a piece of spit on your let's
distract the whole story I was watch it
was earlier don't let the bottom off you
were in the [ __ ] rhythm dehydrated
yeah I know at one point is just
connected both you had like a little
flick spit breathe all the stories run
store water for a bottle of you when I'm
dude ah this poor girl I never
understood with opening access you now
came back good but like you can't attack
the crowd someone else's crowd it's just
bad it's just bad business
yeah it's not your crowd it makes no
sense than anything you you are getting
you get to take advantage of that crowd
yeah I'm doing you a favor it is it is
an amazing opportunity like work on
material and like you get 20 minutes
right with zero expectations yeah how
could you come back hmm it was fun
though you got a good team a good story
Tampa's good Tim's good Sam is a good
City yeah we did Tampa cuz it's like a
theater it's built in the yeah it's
old-school
it's okay it was a Borg is that you
buddy boy yeah yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
not [ __ ] with Tampa and chickens on the
street and [ __ ] and then there's Ben
then there's then there was times when
the openers were like dude like 20-year
vets and they've been they just they
have these 15 20 minutes that will set
the fire and they'll go out then I'll
look at the manager go how has he not
left Buffalo yeah how was he not
headlining yeah the [ __ ] Staples
Center and he's like yeah Oh papa
he's been doing that same 20 for the
last 18 years he's never draw only new
21 he'll eat [ __ ] you only has those 20
and that's it I'll never change oh yeah
and there are monsters yeah and they're
great guys yeah they're monsters but
they're dads and they might be working
at [ __ ] you know that Starbucks oh
[ __ ] but they've had this 20 that is
[ __ ] fire do you feel so interesting
to you tell kids to move to tell a lie
guys who open for you on the road I
don't give anyone advice yeah I'm in
conference three weeks I don't give
anyone advice yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]